high pitch eric is another one of my
favorites because high-pitched eric is
unfiltered do you masturbate
i gave her a friday night watching blue
blood you did on friday night you
watched the blue bloods and you jerked
off to donny when he's on screen
yes i took a nap it was like
9 50 10 minutes before right and as soon
as it came on i went to the bathroom and
jerked off i remember the first time i
saw high pitch eric he was thin and dare
i say handsome how you doing man good
how are you
and it's not a goof that's his voice
it's my real voice and you're saying you
could fix your voice if they kept you
awake this is the part that freaks you
out being kept awake they would work on
your vocal cords yes there then they can
hear how they're lowered but you're
afraid to do it i'm afraid to do it do
you think it'll be too painful yes i am
a huge fan of high pitch eric and i know
some people have problems with him they
feel like wow he's on cameo adam levine
wrote me no yes adam lavina maroon 5 and
of the voice for his birthday his buddy
bought him a personalized high-pitched
message are you kidding me i pitch get
75 bucks for a cameo message you want to
hear it absolutely all right here's what
adam levine got for 75 bucks there you
go hey adam
i want to wish you a very happy
lady birthday
i hope you're having a great
vacation i love that um i hope you're
having that
a great vacation there's like a
and they hope you make a lot of
birdies
this year
who's high pitch
i love you with peace and love
he's running around he's having too much
fun he was at the yankees game but he
was sitting in the 1500 seats you could
see high pitch on tv you know sitting
there i don't know i love him on the
show he is such a good sport we're going
to weigh him in my books and determine
how many books it will take that light's
going to turn green when it gets even
look for the middle light 132.
oh oh
the light's not on yet here comes 133.
133 copies of howard stern comes again
wow
and i love the fact that like he's
always confused about stuff he he says
he's straight but he wants to go on a
date with chris wilding and have sex
with chris wilding he opens the back of
the truck right flatbed truck
i get into it for god knows what reason
you're crazy
and we're just sitting and we're looking
up at the sky you know the middle of new
york 6th avenue yeah and very casually
he just puts his right leg over me over
my torso how'd you get out of the car
with eric
so the only way i really got out of it
and by the way as i was getting out of
it he grabbed my cop eric you gotta go
you gotta go
i agreed
to go with him on valentine's day to go
see sesame street live
that's great why sesame street i want to
see your friends
i love that he's in love with donnie
wahlberg like that's so random he first
approached me at the urinal down the
hallway right and uh eric walked right
up while i was peeing and handed me a
letter
yeah
i went in and i read it and he said he
was a huge fan and wanted to be on blue
bloods little did i know he was
masturbating to blue bloods on friday
nights
yeah and then i can turn to him and say
so eric you're gay
and he goes no
if you were jenny okay do you think you
could blow donny better than jenny oh
absolutely
yeah why is that how are you so
confident you could blow donny better
than jenny why yeah
because i had bigger lips yeah oh wow
are you gay i'm not good you're saying
if he said if he was jenny i think right
i think he's being very honest
it's just great everything about eric is
just perfect peace and love peace and
love